In France, the landmark Notre Dame Cathedral in Paris caught fire.
Footage shows the historic monument engulfed in flames.
In Sudan, Sudanese protest organizers rallied their supporters...
...to gather outside army headquarters in the capital of Khartoum...
...because of an attempt to break up the days-long, sit-in demonstration there, organizers say.
In Venezuela, US Secretary of State Mike Pompeo ends his South American tour...
...with a brief visit to the Colombian border city of Cucuta,...
...where he met with Venezuelan migrants.
Tornadoes kill at least five people across the southern United States...
...as a massive storm system moved across the region and up to the nation's East Coast.
Finally from Taiwan, former US House Speaker Paul Ryan...
...meets Tsai Ing-Wen, president of Taiwan,...
...to mark the 40th anniversary of the Taiwan Relations Act.